[Music]
adam's with us in
boston massachusetts hey adam welcome to
the dave ramsey show
oh thank you i appreciate uh your advice
for this question
so i have a nine-year-old shih tzu that
is getting medical care for an
ulcer in her eye i've already invested
about four hundred dollars
of going to two separate um
emergency care vets for her and at this
point she's gonna need
a surgery which will probably be about a
thousand dollars
i'm trying to decide um at what point
do i say no no more surgery um no more
costs going into this dog
well i've uh i'm old
and i've raised a bunch of dogs or had a
bunch of dogs raised me however you want
to look at it
and i've had the
unbelievable crying day where i've had
to put
them down and i always cry like i'm 12
years old
um because i love dogs i'm a dog guy
i've always had a dog
and i've always you know we talk baby
talk to our dogs we're you know it's
ridiculous right
so i'm a huge animal nut
so the given that the rules that sharon
and i have used over the years
is the first thing i want to do
is i want to make sure
that this is about the dog not about me
because sometimes people will pay a
whole bunch of money to prolong an
animal's life three months
and that's selfish on your part
because the animal is hurting suffering
because you can't be a grown-up and let
go
and that's me i i have to watch myself
because i will do that
the problem is i got the money too right
and so i can make a choice
that's not good for the poor animal um
you know and um i can use examples in
our own life but i won't get into them
but uh where i've had one where i just i
don't want i don't want to make that
trip to the vet
you know and not come home with my dog i
don't i just i can't do it
but on the other hand it's not fair to
the dog so that's the first question you
ask yourself is
are these surgeries and the pain for uh
11 i mean nine nine-year-old shih tzu
i've got one that's 11 right now
and um you know that's about their life
span
and so uh is this dogs is this dog gonna
be okay and live a pain-free life for
another three or four years and you want
to spend a grand
then that would be okay assuming you've
got the grand right
does that make sense it does and
i actually went down the road with that
conversation with a vet to see if maybe
euthanasia would be an option
and because the surgery would correct
the
issue and cure her in essence
they are unwilling to do euthanasia so i
guess my only option would be either to
relinquish the pet
or to go ahead with this surgery at this
point
okay and do you have the money
i do i do i guess um but it just it
it's just a lot of money for an eye yeah
i love my dog i'm
like you know i love him and stuff but i
just didn't know at what point do you
just draw the line you know i had a lady
when i was in college
i was selling real estate in college and
this woman gave me a dalmatian
with papers now i grew up redneck and we
never had a dog that had papers
we had ones that went on the papers but
we didn't have a dog that had papers
right
and so i was so proud i had a dog that
was actually certified or whatever
this dog was meaner than snot by the way
the only mean dog i've ever owned
and the dog had been hit by a car or
something when it was young i ended up
spending 1200
i'm a broke college kid i don't have a
dollar and i end up spending 1200
on this dog's leg that i didn't have and
so
that's the that's the thing you got to
go through and
you know if that vet won't euthanize the
dog it needs to be euthanized
there's other vets or there's um i'm
from the country there's other ways to
handle this
so but i don't want you to have to do
that if you've got the money
and it's the dog's not going to be in
pain i personally would go ahead and do
it if you're not broke
that's exactly right i'd fix a puppy but
if it was mine that's probably what i'd
do
but again i have to go through those
particular
filters when i'm making these decisions
because it's a dog it's not a human